Speaker 1: Facebook has decided to uphold
the ban on Donald Trump and will reassess
the decision in a few months.
This was a decision we knew had been made
a couple of days ago by Facebook's oversight
board, and it was set to be announced this
morning at nine a.m. and as promised, that
right around 9:00 a.m.
Eastern, the company's decision to suspend
Donald Trump on both Facebook and Instagram
was confirmed and extended for at least a
period of several months.
The board did rule that an indefinite suspension
of Trump was not appropriate.
So that time frame has now been amended.
And the board said that they are going to
rereview this at some period of time in the
relative future.
It seems as though it will happen within six
months.
The board asked that Facebook complete the
review within six months and said that maybe
some clear policies could be made to balance
public safety and freedom of expression.
Remember that originally the ban on Donald
Trump from Facebook different than the one
on Twitter.
I mean, every platform had their sort of own
justification was that the risk to public
safety exceeded Facebook's purported desire
to allow freedom of expression.
And they made that decision shortly after
the January 6th Trump riot insurrection of
the US capital.
This was the most aggressive action Facebook
had taken against Trump during his entire
four year term.
And Mark Zuckerberg, the Facebook CEO, said
at the time, quote, We believe the risks of
allowing the president to continue to use
our service during this period are simply
too great.
That decision was then referred to the oversight
board several weeks later because it was such
a significant decision.
They wanted the board to review it and independently
judge whether Trump should remain banned.
And now, indeed, they are saying it will be
I mean, I guess we're saying at least six
months and then it will be reviewed again.
So depending on how you want to interpret
this news, it Trump continues banned and it's
a sledgehammer and cudgel against the free
speech of a former president.
That's the way the right is reacting.
And we'll have some of those reaction clips
maybe tomorrow, depending on what else is
going on.
Maybe not.
On the other hand, the news seems to be signaling
that at some point Trump is coming back.
And my prediction would be that if it's in
six months or five or seven or whatever, at
a certain point the oversight board at Facebook
will determine that at this time, because
things have simmer down or whatever the case
may be at that time, the impetus for providing
a platform for expression to a former president
will override in this kind of balancing act
the risk to public safety.
There will still be a risk to public safety
of allowing Trump back on Facebook, but it
will be overridden given the circumstances
at the time.
Now, even though this is the news here is
they have decided the ban is no longer indefinite.
They've announced it is no longer a permanent
ban.
Fox News couldn't even get the story correct.
Fox News went to air this morning with a story
called Facebook Oversight Board Bans Trump
for life.
That's just inaccurate.
It's the opposite of the decision.
I mean, I guess if you think Trump won't live
six months, I guess in a sense Trump may be
banned for his life, but that is not the story.
Now, it's obvious that if allowed back on
the platform, Donald Trump would immediately
resume using the platform to spread corrosive
lies and weaponized disinformation.
The only question is whether he should be
allowed to do some of that, because there
should be emphasis placed on allowing a former
president to use these platforms to communicate,
even in a situation where someone else, a
sort of mere mortal, so to speak, you know,
a civilian, a normal person, would not be
allowed to do that.
And that's a question that the Facebook board
will answer, presumably in about six months.
Now, in terms of what we're going to get later,
actually, to Donald Trump's desire to communicate
directly with the public, he has launched
now this much promoted new communication platform.
It's just a.
Log and we're going to get to that later,
but there is no question that, you know, six
months from now we will be well into the twenty,
twenty two campaign.
I know it sounds insane because Trump still
hasn't accepted the results of twenty twenty.
Trump still hasn't even accepted the popular
vote results of 2016.
But six months from now, we will be under
a year out from the midterms.
And so Trump's desire to play kingmaker and
to determine who is a real Republican, as
far as he's concerned, that is going to be
riding very high in six months, which will
be early November of twenty twenty one.
So there's no question that we're going to
be hearing more from Trump by then one way
or another.
The question is whether we will be hearing
from him on Facebook.
For now, Trump remains banned, but it is no
longer an indefinite ban and we'll have more
on that as needed.
Maybe tomorrow or maybe not